now he might better force it now by
pushing the pawn but
uh yeah and and i think liam blue's
worked out that this is just winning
simply yeah frank's fighting that's a
good thing okay he gave up his knight
for that very dangerous pawn
just for a pin against the white bishop
but black's rook
is not enough he's not creating any
threats at all and liam is going to
decide this game now by bringing his
bishop back next move white's rook is
going to come down to the first rank
offer a trade of rooks
and
when the pin is broken the game will end
so it's a whole piece isn't it clearly
all extra bishops there's a new uh new
feeling that prague's gonna experience
here losing losing a match
so uh you know this one the first time
this tournament that it won't have gone
to four games for him yeah
both him and magnus they've played four
games every round and there we go prague
throws in the towel and it's decided his
first match low loss a handshake but
zero points today four pragnanda
been on a roll but it stops